how to set up tracking and goals with
Google analytic the first step will be
to gain a code from Google analytic that
will let it executes on your website the
best way to do it is to go to Google
analytic website and click on the admin
section then you could click here and
add a new account you could choose here
between website to your mobile app give
it a meaningful name like demo one in my
case it will be those project and let's
give it a URL and from here of course
you need to decide in which category you
are going to be in our case it's
internet the time zone and some other
aspects of the data sharing that you are
going to do and by clicking getting
tracking ID you're basically accepting
of course the terms of use of Google
analytic and after you accept them
you'll get the tracking code here it is
with the right information how to put it
on your website once we do this
preliminary phase we can jump into
setting our goals the first way to set
goals is because goes a very versatile
way to measure how well our site or app
for phils target objectives you can set
up individual goals for discreet actions
like how many users reach out our Thank
You page what are the top X landing
pages what are the bounce rates on each
one where do people interact with the
site let's take for example my own site
and set up a goal I'm clicking on the
admin to get into the admin tab and then
I'm clicking on goals